I used to work at CERN and I still go
out and work there a lot so I work on
their data and I work on mathematical
models of particle physics and how and
forces and the early universe and my
area of work is really between the data
and theory trying to inform one by the
other and sort of back things back and
forwards and up until last year I spent
all my career work working on the
supersymmetry theory which is a theory
of particle physics and but we thought
that the Large Hadron Collider
experiment at CERN was going to produce
particles predicted new particles
predicted by the supersymmetry theory
and it hasn't there's this hope hasn't
panned out so I've kind of shifted what
what I'm working on but the
supersymmetry theory was beautiful to
work on for a while it was it had very
lofty ideals it it was it was a bridge
to theories of everything theory like
mathematical theories of all particles
and forces which tried to explain
everything about our universe so you
know dark matter how forces work what
what women made of you know what light
is everything but you the problem with
them was you had to make quite a lot of
assumptions to to predict just a few
things that you could measure and test
in an experiment and then we looked in
the experiment and they weren't there so
yeah so I had to rethink last year and
now I'm working in a different mode I'm
looking at the data and looking for
glitches and so we predict with the
standard model of particle physics
that's the current knowledge that we
have we predict how the data should look
from the collisions between two protons
at CERN at high energies and we look for
cases where the the model disagrees the
prediction does
agrees with what's what scene and then
for that that for me is an opportunity
so then we we jump on that and try and
explain it but explain it in a very
simple way we kind of just bung in an
extra force or an extra particle that
would explain the what scene and then we
do some proper phenomenology so we try
and suggest other ways in which it may
be tested we first of all checked that
it's consistent with all other data and
then suggest other ways you can save the
data to look for these new particles or
forces and then you know go one step
further in the theoretical direction so
this is more we call it bottom-up
science working from the data and where
you've got really solid foundation and
you think you know what's going on and
then making hypotheses away from that so
I'm enjoying this new way of working
it's certainly quite different to the
previous way where you try and solve
everything
and make loads of assumptions that's
what that we called top-down you know
it's like you start from pure thought
thought and then try and get to your
experimental observations but for me
anyway that that that approach hasn't
panned out so you know I'm trying a new
approach and it's and it's a lot of fun
so this change in starting from a data
rather than theory does this mean that
you've sort of given up hope of finding
supersymmetrical particle right okay so
it's the work still focused on
supersymmetry are you that's just a
belief you have but you can't like no I
okay so looking at my own work at the
moment the way the way I answer this
question is the way for me to make
progress right now is not to work on
supersymmetry and the reason is because
we know from the data that the Large
Hadron Collider has seen already that in
the next few years there's not going to
be a big discovery of super
supersymmetric particles otherwise we
would have seen small fluctuations in
the data already so in the next years
for me that's not whether discovery is
going to be so I'm looking elsewhere but
still you know you can't help in your
heart of hearts
believe in this beautiful theory which
explains a really important fact that we
otherwise don't understand and that fact
is why is the Higgs boson so light so if
you if you do calculations on Higgs
bosons and they're they're affected by
quantum fluctuations the little the
seething of space-time in terms of other
particles and they're they're special in
that they feel those fluctuations
extremely sensitively and if you do
back-of-the-envelope calculations those
fluctuations should increase its mass by
something like a billion billion times
more than it then it's been measured to
be so this this is a puzzle that we
don't understand with our current theory
it's not explained why is the Higgs
boson so light and how is it able to
stay so light with these quantum
fluctuations supersymmetry explains this
it doesn't mean it's the only that
doesn't mean it's the only explanation
but the other ones don't work or you
know we haven't really found a decent of
the one so that's why we were so keen on
it and why we thought we might be able
to find supersymmetric particles as a
signal that the theory was right at the
Large Hadron Collider so you know if in
I don't know five or ten years time some
signals start appearing from the data of
course I'm going to jump back right back
on it right but for the moment I think
in terms of progress it's it's more
fruitful for me personally to look
elsewhere for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you